Welcome.
You are about to do
something very special, which
is to negotiate
the future of work.
This video is
designed to help you
know what you need
to know to navigate
the software and the
tools and methods
to help you be successful
in this process.
What you see on the screen
are a series of slides.
We'll spend more time with
some, less with others.
All of them will be available
to you on the course website.
Here's what you need to
know at the beginning.
Once you agree to be part
of this negotiations,
we want you to sign up
and we want you to commit.
Because in the
negotiations there
will be yourself and
three or four other people
in appropriate roles, and
they'll all be depending on you
to stay through to agreement.
And, frankly, that's
how you'll all learn.
What are the roles?
The roles in the negotiation
match key stakeholders
in society.
Labor, management,
government, and education.
And essentially, each of you
will be taking on one of these
roles-- they'll be assigned
through the course platform--
and that will tell
you who you're
going to represent in figuring
out the future of work.
Now, once you're
assigned to your role,
you'll come to the website
platform for this negotiation.
That's what you see
on the screen here.
It, again, reiterates what
are the different roles
in the exercise and
gives you some background
about the assignment.
And then for all
four of the roles--
there's two here and two more--
you'll see some
additional information
to help you know
what you need to know
to be effective in your role.
You'll see there's
a Next button--
I just checked it--
that will move you
on to the next
screen, which is where
you start to fill out some of
the key information we need.
There's different universities
that are participating in this.
Check which one
you're coming from.
You will be assigned
a group number
which you want to assign.
And then there's other
demographic information
that you'll fill
out on education,
whether you've been a
member of a union, age,
and other factors.
They're all required except the
gender item which is optional.
But again, once you
finish filling out
those different items,
you'll click Next
and you go on to a screen
that now asks you to tell us
about your preferences
or priorities
before negotiations begins.
You'll see that there's
five different issues
about workforce
capability, all of which
could be subjects
of negotiation,
and we want you to rank order
them from your top priority
to your second, third,
fourth, and fifth.
No ties here.
You have to pick one,
two, three, four or five
for each of the five items.
There's also some questions
about representation,
about organizational
performance, about compensation
and rewards and
incentives for managers,
as well as work family
kinds of issues.
All of these are questions that
indicate your priorities going
in, and, frankly,
that get you thinking
about what's at stake as you
think about the future of work.
Finally, before we go
on to the next screen,
in each of the five
big categories--
each of which had
five sub questions--
we want you to rank
order those in terms
of what's important in the
role that you're playing.
And again, you'll press Next
and go on to the next screen.
Here there's a couple of
short attitude questions
about cooperation
and competition.
Again, these will be quick and
they give us your attitudes
before we begin the bargaining.
That's the setup.
Now we're getting
ready to bargain.
You'll see that there's
a slide that tells you
and a set of materials
about preparation.
The key thing about
preparation is
to not just think about your
own priorities, and frankly,
your underlying interests, but
to think about the priorities
and the interest--
what's really at stake--
for the people in
the other roles.
And so the preparation
materials will get you up
to speed on moving
through it quickly.
But there's a lot here to
read that will help you.
In negotiations, we say
the three things that
are most important are
preparation, preparation
and preparation.
Just like in real estate,
location, location,
and location.
This time is time
that's well spent.
At this point now you've
committed to a bargain,
you've got your role, you've
done your preparation,
and we're ready to
begin negotiations.
I'm going to say a little
bit about the negotiations
and then we're going to talk
about what happens afterwards.
You'll see that there's a
link to the settlement form--
which I'll show you in a minute,
but there's also, I'm sorry.
There's also a page
that's not on here
but that will come
on your screen that
will let you print out all
of your preparation choices
either in a PDF or
in a printed document
so that you've got
that in front of you.
When it comes to the
actual bargaining,
I'm going to just give
you a very simple example.
Let's say in the
opening statement--
and you'll all make
opening statements--
and this is, of course,
virtual negotiations
so you'll be writing it
out online for the others
in your group to see--
the folks who are in the
worker's role might say,
there ought to be
more government
grants for skills training.
The person in the
government role may say,
we're willing to provide some
funding but only in areas that
are skill shortages in society.
Management might say,
yes, but the grant should
be to the employer since they
know what the skills are not
just to the individuals.
The education
providers say, this
needs to be part of an
integrated education system
and so these funds for
curriculum development
ought to come to the
educational institutions
so that they can provide the
new training that's needed.
Government may say,
that's all great
but, we need to have
a funding mechanism.
Let's say, $.01 per hour
for people that work.
Management, as you see
here, might say, well,
we're education
providers so we should
be able to get
development funds too.
Ultimately, the management,
the workers, and the education
providers might come
together and say,
we need to provide governance
and insight and input
into this government initiative.
And together they might then
outline what an agreement is.
But as you can see, there's a
series of iterative proposals
and counter proposals that are
all part of the negotiations.
And in the end, we're not
looking for a simple sentence,
we had an agreement on
government funded education.
We're really looking for
two or three paragraphs
that says who does what,
what are they agreeing to,
how will it be funded, and
what are the outcomes involved.
Now, we've done this many times,
and it turns out this issue--
support for worker training--
is a common issue
that people pick.
We want you to push the
envelope about what's needed
in the future of work, so we're
going to say that at least
for your first two agreements
they cannot be agreements that
are on this issue of
government funded education,
but on other issues that are
among the many 25 issues that
we've highlighted
in five categories.
And then if you want
to come back to this
as part of a package, great.
But the point is, push the
envelope, do something new.
Once you have an
agreement you'll
then follow the URL
to a screen that
looks like what you see here.
It says it's part two.
And again, it'll ask you what
group number you're at, what
institution are you doing this.
And then you'll find that
there's a question about what
role are you in, how many people
are part of this agreement,
and what were their roles?
So obviously, if you are
an education institution,
you would check management,
labor, and federal government
and leave education
blank on question five.
But at that point you
go to the next screen
and this is your chance to
indicate what you actually
agreed to.
You'll click, let's say,
fair treatment and a screen
will open up saying, write
into this what you agreed upon.
This is important.
Each of you will be entering
the agreement separately.
So if there's four people
in the negotiations,
there will be four
entries of the text.
It's perfectly OK
for you to each cut
and splice the same language.
But the key thing--
and by the way,
if you put in
different language,
that's evidence that it might
not be a very stable agreement.
But the point is, you
each put in your language
because we also ask you to
each rate how important is this
in terms of your role
and how satisfied are you
with the process, not
just the substance,
to get to this agreement.
And this way we can
hear from each of you
in the negotiations.
And of course, there's
a space for you
to say if there's anything
else that you want to put.
And that completes the process.
There's a link here that
will let you come back
and enter a second
or third agreement.
And when you're done--
when you're done-- you will
have done something very special
which is you will have
negotiated an agreement
about the future of work.
People who are in positions
of power and authority
are interested to
see what comes out
of the negotiations
in this course.
We will try to sum
up the agreements
and look for insights and
lessons around which there
might be the kind of
alignment that could actually
change things in
society and ensure
that the institutions of
work are better designed
to serve the needs of
yourself and others
in the future generations.
Thank you very much.